occupy London appears to be the latest
victim of Facebook's recent spree of
shutting down pages the social justice
movement had its page taken down for
several hours the movement says this is
not the first time Facebook has tried to
censor its content
occupy London is a social justice
movement founded in 2011 it's part of a
global movement that's organized
hundreds of protests against financial
elites the movement says it's our
founding values are equality and
diversity occupy London has a
significant social media presence about
a hundred and fifty thousand followers
on Facebook now some say that certain
pro-palestine posts by Occupy London may
be to blame for Facebook's action we
asked Facebook for a comment the social
media giant has since apologized to
Occupy London saying it was all a big
mistake
George Bardo one of the movements
activists is not convinced if it were
just a you know a sort of a blip and
mistake out of the blue it wouldn't
probably wouldn't mean very much at all
but the problem is this is part of a
massive rearguard action I think by the
establishment you know anyone can go
online and see the evidence of this
themselves and Chris Hedges who's a
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist has
been one of those exposing most that the
details of this but effectively what's
happened is it in the name of dealing
with fake news and many progressive
websites that have been a major part of
you know Bernie Sanders Jeremy Corbyn
etc they found their traffic going down
you know sickening um
websites like AlterNet TruthDig that are
you know mainstream progressive websites
have seen their traffic go down by 70
percent literally and these are
algorithms devised in private that
nobody can inspect and that have a huge
impact on what information the world
gets to see about what's going on and
that's a hugely significant issue going
forward the relevant thing today in
terms of our discussion is that occupy
is still a very powerful force online
and has millions of people engaging with
its posts and so it's very important
that they and others like them are not
in the name of fake news effectively
removed from most people's internet
searches and I think this is a huge
issue going forward bear in mind that
Google and Facebook are very very close
to the American establishment
you know the Washington Post is owned by
Jeff Bezos who also owns and
and not surprisingly he's very keen on
using the Washington Post to make sure
that the Internet allows his articles to
come up at the top researchers in
neurons
you